J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK.
We were talking about acid
derivatives.
We started last time talking
about acyl insertions,
although I'm not sure I
mentioned the term.
And then about reactivity at the
position adjacent to
carbonyles, alpha-reactivity and
condensation reactions,
which are related to that, which
are chapters 18 and 19
in the Jones text.
So acyl insertion is to put an
atom in the bond between the R
and the carbonyle group, the
acyl group.
So you just move the R aside and
put X in there.
So X can be an oxygen, the
Baeyer-Villiger reaction of
ketones.
It can be an NH group.
so you can make an amine from a
ketone.
It can be a CH2 group inserted
into the carboxylic acid.
So in the first case, you get a
ketone transformed to an
ester, in the second case, a
ketone transformed to amide.
In the third case, it's an acid
goes to an acid, but it's
an acid that's longer by one
carbon.
Can you think of any other ways
of having an acid and
making an acid that's longer by
one carbon?
It has to be sort of a
roundabout way.
You could go from the acid to
the alcohol, from the alcohol
to the halide.
Now you've got something you can
make reactive.
It's reactive in itself, the
halide.
You could displace it with a
carbon nucleophile.
That would add one carbon to the
chain.
So it could be CN, right?
And then we know you can
hydrolyze CN to make
carboxylic acid.
So that would be one unit
longer.
Or once you have the alkyl
halide, you could make it into
a Grignard reagent, or an alkyl
lithium, and add CO2,
which is a carboxylic acid again
one way.
So there are many ways, as we
said last
time, to skin the cat.
But one way is this
Arndt-Eistert procedure, which
gives good yields.
So we were starting to talk
about the Baeyer-Villiger
reaction last time.
And I'm going to write some more
on the
board here with this.
It's supposed to turn that
projector off.
I think I'll just turn it off
and we'll use the side ones
for the rest of the lecture.
OK.
So the Baeyer-Villiger reaction,
as we said, starts
with a ketone and reacts with a
peroxy acid.
Which is, of course, an acid.
It's got a pKa, I think, about 7
or something like that.
So we can get the anion here.
We could add the acid and make
the analog of a hemiketal, but
instead... We don't have a
leaving group here that we can
leave. It looks like the only
leaving group is that.
But there's a fancy way to do
it, which is, this can make
these electrons of high energy.
So we can use those electrons to
displace the leaving group.
So now we have COR' OR.
So we've inserted that oxygen
between the originally acyl
carbon and the R group.
So we have an ester, plus, of
course, the carboxylic acid,
which was a good leaving group,
the anion of the carboxylic
acid.
Now, I indicated here that we
had different R groups, or
could have different R groups, R
and R prime.
The question obviously arises of
which one migrates, which
ester do you get?
Now, this is called migratory
aptitude, and it comes in a
reasonable order.
H tertiary radical, secondary,
primary, and CH3.
But I didn't tell you whether
this is increasing or
decreasing in migratory
aptitude.
So what is the group that
shifts?
Is it a cation, a radical, or an
anion?
What have I shown with my curved
arrows?
When R moves over, does it move
without electrons, with
one electron, or with a pair of
electrons?
STUDENT: A Pair of electrons.
PROFESSOR: With a pair of
electrons.
So it's R minus that moves.
It's a methide. Or an alkide,
shift,
we say, like a methide shift.
So do you think methyl is the
best or the worst at shifting,
say, compared with a tertiary?
Which should be the best?
Suppose it were a cation that
were shifting.
Which would be best?
What do you think?
Liang, what do you think?
Which is the best cation?
Methyl, a primary, a secondary,
a tertiary?
STUDENT: Tertiary.
PROFESSOR: Can't hear very well.
STUDENT: Tiertiary.
PROFESSOR: Yes, tertiary.
So, if it's just the opposite
with anions.
So if it's an anion that's
shifting,
then one would predict that
methyl would be the thing that
would be easiest to shift, and
tertiary would be the hardest.
But in fact, H is better than
this.
And this is better, better,
better, right?
So it's not the best anion that
shifts.
It's the best cation that
Doesn't that seem curious?
But the reason is that it
doesn't break completely away
to become R minus.
Its electrons, which have been
boosted in energy by having
this charge next door, are being
shared
with sigma* here.
So in fact, those electrons have
to be given to something
else in order for the
rearrangement to take place.
If it were an alkide shift in
which the R pulled away to
become anion, and then attacked
sigma*, then the
best anion would do it.
But that's not the way it goes.
In fact, exactly the opposite.
Because it actually is giving up
electrons in
the process of shifting.
These electrons are being given
to sigma*.
So it's the best cation migrates
fastest, which seems
sort of funny, when you say that
it's an alkide shift.
One other feature is that if the
group that's migrating is
chiral, then, since you're just
moving these electrons
over, it's not a any kind of
backside attack.
So the R in the product will
retain stereochemistry.
OK.
This is the Baeyer-Villiger
reaction.
So that inserts an oxygen.
Then we said that the Beckmann
rearrangement--
notice that these are old.
Remember, the Baeyer-Villiger
was done at the same time that
Gomberg was there, essentially,
1900, roughly.
The Beckmann rearrangement is
1886.
This was done by one of the few
organic chemists who was
also a physical chemist,
Beckmann.
He invented a very, very
sensitive thermometer, as
well, and worked in the same
department with Ostwald, whom
we mentioned before.
But the Beckmann rearrangement
puts a nitrogen in.
So it starts with a ketone like
cyclohexanone and inserts
a nitrogen in the bond between
carbon and oxygen.
And the reagent that does it is
hydoxyl amine, and then
treated with acid.
So we already talked about what
amines do with ketones.
They give imines.
And it's especially good to do
for amines, you remember, that
have unshared pairs that are
interacting unfavorably.
So you lose water and generate
what's called an oxime.
Now, the Beckmann rearrangement
happens when
this is treated with strong
acid.
You could imagine it protonating
the nitrogen.
It probably does that.
But when it does it, it comes
off again.
But it can protonate the oxygen,
as well.
And now we have the leaving
group.
But N+ doesn't look like such a
very good cation.
So in fact, what you use is the
electrons here.
These electrons shift up, so
it's very much like the R
minus, or R plus, if you wish,
shifting in that case.
Pardon me.
This is a C. I'll write it
explicitly.
And we have the N here, and a
double bond here.
And notice that since these
electrons left this carbon,
there should be a positive
charge on this
carbon in the formula.
Right?
So since this is done with
water, present, we can put
water on there.
Well, actually, let me draw a
resonance structure of this
first. Notice that it's hard to
pull these electrons away
to leave this, what would appear
to be a
vinyl cation, right?
But remember that the nitrogen
has a pair of
electrons in its pi system.
Have I got that right?
Yeah.
It's got another pair of
electrons.
These electron are displacing
this, so they're coming in
backside to that orbital.
But there's another pair of
electrons on the nitrogen, and
at the same time that these
electrons are leaving from
this carbon, these electrons can
go toward that carbon.
And if that happens, we get a
resonance structure of this
thing which has the positive
charge on the nitrogen.
Right?
So it's not as unstable as you
might have thought.
But at any rate, when we add
water and lose a proton, we
can get this, which is of course
related allylically, if
we just shift the proton, to
this amide.
So we've indeed inserted NH into
the carbonyl-to-alpha-
carbon bond.
Incidentally, this particular
amine,
this particular lactone--
a lactam, pardon me,
a lactone is a cyclic ester,
a lactam is a cyclic amine, or
amide--
and this particular one is
called caprolactam, and it's
of some commercial interest.
Because if you hydrolyze it,
it becomes this amine, which, of
course, can cyclize,
the amine can form an amide with
the COOH.
But it can also form polymers
where the amine attacks the
carboxylic acid of another
molecule.
So instead of a ring, one can
then get a chain, and you can
get a very, very long chain.
This is called nylon.
The polymer--
I'll write it this way--
is called nylon-6.
So the 6 means that there are
six carbons in the chain
between the amide groups.
Now again, we could wonder, in a
case where we have different
Rs here, which are migrates.
That is, which one gets next to
the nitrogen.
Now, one might think it would be
something like this up
here, where the best cation
would move, because its
electrons trends are being
shared with the sigma*,
that's allowing the water to
leave.
But it's actually not that.
Because you'll notice, there are
two different isomers of
oximes, and if you're careful,
you can separate them.
And it turns out that in this
one, R migrates, but in this
one, R prime migrates,
which doesn't surprise you,
because
it's a backside attack.
Displacement of the water.
So it inserts, the nitrogen
inserts, in the antibond, the
one that's away from the OH.
OK.
So that's the Beckmann
rearrangement.
And then the Arndt-Eistert
reaction, which is the
homologation, the one that makes
an acid one unit longer.
So you have a carboxylic acid,
and insert CH2 in this bond.
And the way that one goes is
first, to react with SOCl2.
What will that do to the acid?
SOCl2, remember that reagent?
STUDENT: Switches OH out for Cl.
PROFESSOR: Replaces OH with Cl,
the same as it does in ROH.
So we have an acid chloride.
And now, nucleophiles can do
association-dissociation and
displace the chloride.
And the particular nucleophile
that's used in this case is
called diazomethane.
It's a very poisonous and
unstable compound.
It's a good idea not to work
with it.
It's one of these interesting
molecules that you can't draw
a Lewis structure without
putting charge in it, which is
sort of a tip that it might be
reactive.
But you can draw not only that
resonance structure,
but also this one.
The nitrogen in the middle has
to be positive, but the
negative charge can be written
on either end of the molecule.
It's probably better to put it
on nitrogen than to put it on
carbon, but the reactivity is of
the carbon.
So these are the electrons that
come up.
And then loss again,
so substitution at the acyl
carbon, as we've
been speaking about.
So now we have CH2N plus triple
bond N. Which loses a
proton to give ROCHN2--
OK.
I'll draw it this way.
Have I done it right?
Yeah.
OK, good.
Plus minus--
which is called a diazoketone.
Now, it doesn't surprise you
that
diazoketones, when heated--
and it's often done in the
presence of silver--
lose nitrogen to give an unusual
compound, because
there's just two bonds to that
carbon.
It's like a carbene.
So it has a vacant orbital and
an unshared pair.
And now you can see how we're
set up for the rearrangement.
These electrons can shift just
as they did in the Beckmann
rearrangement; just as they did
in the
Baeyer-Villiger reaction.
But at the same time, these
electrons can come here to
make a double bond.
So we have O=C=CHR.
And notice that this, if we
trace through this carbon
here, became this carbon, became
this carbon, became
this carbon,
and it's now this carbon.
So we inserted that carbon
between the carbonyl carbon
and the R group.
Now, we've seen this kind of
compound before.
It's an acid derivative.
It's a ketene.
So it can add water, as we've
discussed before, to give
RCHCOOH, which accomplishes what
we wanted to do.
CH2 now, because of the H from
the water.
OK.
So that's the Arndt-Eistert
procedure, which lengthens a
carboxylic acid by one unit.
I want to speak a little bit
about--the rest of the stuff
we're going to talk about with
acid derivatives, is reaction
at the alpha-position.
That is, making an anion at the
alpha-position and using that.
So like an enolate.
But first we should look at the
acidity of these compounds.
So I'll just use the slide to
talk about that.
OK.
So the pKa of acid aldehyde is
17, right?
Acetone, we talked about this
before, is
slightly less acidic.
The anion isn't quite as stable.
19, two orders of magnitude in
the equilibrium constant.
Now, the ester is another five
orders of
magnitude less acidic.
Right?
The equilibrium constant is 10
to the fifth smaller.
Why is it that the ester is less
prone to form the anion
by losing that red proton than a
ketone is?
I could make the opposite
argument.
I could say oxygen is electron e
withdrawing, which would
make it easy to form an anion.
So there must be something else
that goes in the opposite
direction that's even more
important.
What is it?
Ruoyi?
STUDENT: The unshared pair on O.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's right.
What allows you to form the
anion at this position?
In these cases, it's
stabilization by mixing with
the LUMO, pi*.
But in this case, the LUMO is
always already being used to
stabilize the electrons of the
oxygen.
In fact, you could make the same
argument here, in terms
of hyperconjugation.
That the pi* here is being used
to stabilize the
electrons in the CH bond.
So when that vacant orbital, the
pi*, mixes with the
occupied orbital, whether it's
CH bond or, even higher, the
unshared pair of oxygen, then
they mix, and the vacant
orbital becomes higher and less
able to stabilize the
anion on the carbon here.
So that's understood.
Now, notice that a cyanide
group, as we said before, a
so-called nitrile, has much the
same
character as a carbonyl.
In fact, this has the same
acidity as the ester does.
Now, in an amide, so this amide,
has a pKa of 18.
Does that make sense to you?
What would you have predicted?
Ayesha?
If the aldehyde is here when you
have a bond next door, you
get a little bit of raising the
vacant orbital, so it's
not so good.
Unshared pair on oxygen is even
more important and makes
it not acidic.
What would you expect if,
instead of oxygen here, if I
had nitrogen?
How about its unshared pair?
STUDENT: The nitrogen pair would
be less shared because
it has a larger nuclear charge.
PROFESSOR: Aha.
You've got everything right
except the periodic table.
Nitrogen comes before oxygen, so
nitrogen has less nuclear
charge than oxygen, so it's
unshared pair
is higher in energy.
So what would you expect?
STUDENT: It would be more
shared.
PROFESSOR: It would mix even
more with pi*,
pi* would go up even more.
And it should be less acidic, it
should be greater than 24.
And the reason is that that's
not what ionizes.
What ionizes is a hydrogen from
the nitrogen.
So the amide is a little bit
like a carboxylic acid.
So it's not comparable with
these others, actually.
But if you put two R groups on
the nitrogen, so it doesn't
have a hydrogen it can lose,
then indeed it's less acidic
than the ester, which is what
you predicted once you get the
periodic table right.
Now, you can do even better if
you have two carbonyls.
So notice that all these are
weaker acids than water.
So if you put them in with
hydroxide, the equilibrium
will have the proton on them,
not on the water.
So you can, especially in the
cases up here, they're close
enough to water-- water's about
16, 15.7--
they're close enough that there
is some anion at
equilibrium, a significant
amount, so you can do
reactions with it.
But mostly, it's not in that
form.
Mostly it's in the protonated
But if you have two carbonyls,
then it becomes
quite acidic.
And we spoke before, when we
were talking about the
Mitsunobu reaction, about active
methylene compounds.
Methylene groups, CH2 groups,
that are activated by two
adjacent pi* orbitals, so that
then they become much
more acidic.
This one has a pKa of 5.
And if we have two methyl
groups, it's like going from
here to here.
The pKa is 9.
In fact, it looks uncannily good
for that, because if you
got two orders of magnitude by
putting on one methyl group,
from H to methyl, here when you
put on two, you get four
orders of magnitude.
That's spurious in how good the
agreement is.
Because you see, if you put
ester on, instead of the
methyl, as we did here, ester
instead of methyl, the pKa
goes up, as it did here.
But here it went up five orders
of magnitude.
Here the acidity went up only
two orders of magnitude.
So they're really not additive
the way we were talking about,
but it's in the right direction.
If you have two esters, then
it's another
two orders of magnitude.
If you have nitrogen, it goes up
five orders of magnitude
for the reason that we--
in fact, compared to this one,
it went up
seven orders of magnitude.
Over here, compared to the
ester, to the nitrogen, it
went up six orders of magnitude,
so that one looks
reasonable.
And finally, if you have two
nitrile groups, it's still
quite acidic.
And notice that all these are
stronger acids than water,
except the one here, which was
deactivated by the unshared
pair of the nitrogen.
So if you put these with base,
they'll be in the anionic form
with hyroxide or alkoxide.
OK.
So you can get these anions from
the simple compounds--
a small amount at equilibrium in
strong base-- and for the
doubly activated compounds, in
high concentration, if you put
strong base in there.
In fact, if you use an even
stronger base, like lithium
diisopropylamide--
so amide, remember, is a
confusing name, because it
means both the functional group
O=C-N, but it
also means a nitrogen anion, and
you just have to know from
context what you're talking
about.
So anyhow, this is a nitrogen
anion.
So it's a strong anion.
The pKa is 36.
So if you were to take this that
you don't get very good
formation of pulling off this
hydrogen, the one that's much
deactivated,
but you put it with this very
strong base--
this one has a pKa of 25,
but this one has a pKa of 36--
so you have an equilibrium
constant of 10 to the eleventh,
favoring formation
of the anion.
So you could make 100%,
essentially, or just one part
in 10 to the eleventh, not that
way, if you use
this very strong base.
So sometimes, even these
alpha-anions that are difficult
to make, if you use a really
strong base, you can
get them all made.
So you have complete formation,
even of the amide
enolate, and not just a little
bit of equilibrium.
And noticed that it's a hindered
base.
It's not dimethyl or diethyl.
It's diisopropyl.
And you want it to be hindered,
because otherwise,
this H isn't so very easy to
attack.
It would also be possible to
attack the
carbonyl group, pi*.
Add the nitrogen to this carbon,
and
lose the other nitrogen.
You don't want that to happen,
so you use a hindered one that
can only get at the hydrogen out
there.
Doesn't attack the enolate.
Now, when you make these things,
you have a
nucleophilic alpha-carbon.
That's why you make them.
Carbon, remember, in the ways
we've
talked about it mostly, is an
electrophile, R-halogen.
The pi* of C=O, our low LUMOs.
Here's a carbon that's a high
HOMO, the unshared pair here
on that alpha-carbon.
So this allows you then to form
carbon-carbon bonds with
the other kinds, the
electrophilic carbons, by
using that unshared pair to form
a new bond.
OK.
So let's look at some examples
of that.
And it could be done either with
acid- or base-catalysis
via, in the acid case, enol, and
in the base
case, enolate anion.
And you know you know how to do
this.
I'm going to just zip through it
quickly.
So a proton comes in.
In the acid-catalyzed case, you
get this cation, which is
very stabilized, because of the
unshared pair
on oxygen next door.
But that can lose a proton to
generate an enol.
But now, in the case of
hydrogen-deuterium exchange,
it's interesting.
Because if D comes up, we can
reverse the reactions.
We could have reversed it this
way, and put a proton on.
But if you have a deuteron
available, then you can do it
this way, and go to there, and
now lose this D plus.
And what we've done is exchange,
in the alpha-position,
deuterium in place of hydrogen.
So that's the acid-catalyzed
mechanism, which doesn't
surprise you.
You can also do it with base
catalysis.
You can have base come in and
take the proton, generating an
enolate anion, which of course
has this resonance structure.
And now we have this, as we had
here, a
nucleophilic carbon.
We also have a nucleophilic
carbon here.
So we can, in the enolate, we
could bring in
deuterated water.
So either acid or base allows
you to exchange those protons.
And if there's more than one
proton in that alpha-position,
you can exchange the others, as
well.
Now, notice that you can also
racemize in this way.
Because if the other things
attached to this carbon were A
and B, you can go through
exactly the same scheme--
acid or base.
But there's now configuration
here.
So if the H is in front of the
plane here, in this case, when
the H plus comes back on, it
could come either from the
front or from the back.
Because this thing is planar,
and this thing
is planar, not chiral.
So we've lost the memory of
whether the thing was right-
or left-handed.
So it could come in from the
back just as easily as from
the front, and then we racemize.
So either by deuterium exchange,
or by racemization,
you can measure the rate at
which enolate
is formed and destroyed.
You could also do alpha-
halogenation.
And it's exactly the same scheme
again.
The only difference is, once you
get the enol or the
enolate, you react it with a
halogen.
I've chosen to show iodine here.
You can do it with chlorine or
bromine as well.
So you can make an alpha-halo
ketone.
Nothing special here.
Now, the product we made was an
iodomethyl ketone.
But we could also do the
reaction with that.
If there's another hydrogen
here, we could do the
acid-catalyzed or the
base-catalyzed, and
get a diiodo compound.
Or can we?
In fact, in this case, only one
of the pathways works.
And the reason is that the
iodine, the halogen, is
electron withdrawing.
So it gives positive charge to
that carbon--
partial positive charge.
That means that if you went up
here, you would be putting two
positive charges next to one
another, which isn't so great.
So in fact, the acid catalyzed
pathway disappears after
you've added the first iodine.
So you can put one in, one
iodine, one chlorine, one
bromine, but you can't put the
second one in, because you
can't, with acid catalysis, get
the enol.
But if you have a positive
charge there, that's all the
better for losing the proton and
getting the enolate.
So this is even faster, the
second one.
And what do you think happens
next?
If you have another hydrogen
there, right?--
so there's the base catalyzed
one works--
but now you can do it with a
diiodomethylketone and make a
triiodomethylketone.
OK?
So that's great.
What happens next with base?
Well, you can't have anymore
hydrogens on that one.
So if you brought in hydroxide
at this stage, it would attack
the carbonyl.
But when it does that, you could
imagine the OH coming
off again, although it's not
such a good leaving group.
There's a better leaving group.
What's the better leaving group?
CI3.
With three halogens on the
carbon, it's a sufficiently
good anion that it can leave. So
we can unzip in that
direction, one of these
association-dissociation
mechanisms, and get that.
Because and then, of course, you
want to
transfer the proton--
the pKa of the HCI3 is about 14,
so it's more
acidic than water is.
OK.
Now that's neat.
Because that compound,
iodoform--
remember, CHCI3 is chloroform,
this is iodoform--
but whereas chloroform is a
colorless liquid, iodoform is
a yellow solid.
So this provided, in the days
before there was NMR--
like if you had a methyl ketone
now, you'd look for a
methyl singlet shifted down
field at a
certain position.
We know from NMR how you would
identify it,
and in the carbon NMR, you'd
look at a particular place.
Right?
But in the days before there was
spectroscopy to identify
these things, how would you
would know if you had a methyl
ketone? You reacted it in water
with base and iodine,
and see whether you get a bright
yellow solid.
So this is a picture
[fumbling with projection
controls]
and you can see, here are two
test tubes.
This one had a methyl ketone in
it, that one didn't.
This one has a yellow
precipitate.
So that was a handy way of
identifying methyl ketones in
the days before spectroscopy.
Now, you can do this
alpha-halogenation with other
carbonyl groups, as well.
For example, carboxylic acids.
So we've seen before that you
can make an acid
chloride in this way.
And since I had it animated, I
decided to put it here so you
can review it, if you want to.
And that's how you get the acid
chloride.
But one of the most charmingly
named reactions is the
Hell-Volhard-Zelinsky reaction,
sometimes called the
HVZ reaction.
But if you remember
Hell-Volard-Zelinsky, that's
another one you can impress your
roommates with.
So it was Hell did it first, and
then Volhard, and then
Zelinsky, at about two year
intervals flanking 1885.
So the Hell-Volhard-Zelinsky--
I forget whether I've got this
animated here or not--
involves PBr3 and bromine.
So the same way that SOCl2 can
make an acid chloride from an
acid, so can PBr3.
So the HVZ reaction.
Carboxylic acid reacts with PBr3
to give the acid
chloride, or bromide.
But the acid bromide is very
good at forming an enol.
And if you have bromine present,
bromine can attack
the double bond, because the
cation will be stabilized with
oxygen next door.
So then when you lose the
proton, you have
alpha-bromination, bromination
adjacent to
the carbonyl group.
So this was easy to do, because
the acid bromide is
good at forming the enol.
But now it looks like you would
need to keep making the
acid bromide in order to
continue doing this reaction.
But in fact, this can be
catalytic.
Why can it be catalytic?
Why do you need only a little
bit?
You need a full mole of this, of
course.
Because this can react with
acid.
So it displaces the bromide, and
we have Br, so that the
brominated product, but now in
the form of an acid anhydride.
A different acid derivative.
But we also have Br minus, which
can attack here and then
this comes--
yeah.
What have I done wrong?
Oh, I'm losing it.
Yeah.
Right?
And then back here.
Because I didn't have the Br, I
wasn't thinking right.
So now we have the acid, plus
the other product
you can see is Br.
So we traded which one was acid
bromide and which one was
carboxylic acid.
So now this can give this, and
this is a
cycle that goes around.
So you only need this to get it
started, to get the first
bromide, and the subsequent
bromides can come from that.
And the actual product, then,
ultimately is--
remember, H plus came off here--
so the ultimate product is the
alpha-brominated acid.
I was hoping I'd get further
than this.
I'm going to go--
well, let's see.
Yeah, I'll go just this slide.
So alpha-alkylation.
We promised before that the real
advantage of having these
carbon nucleophiles is the
possibility of putting an R
group on there.
So you do this with--
see, what do I have here?
So you use a base, you get an
enolate from
your ketone or aldehyde.
And now, this you react with
something like methyl iodide,
so an electrophilic carbon,
sigma*.
And you can make a new
carbon-carbon bond,
alpha.
So the same way we could put
bromine in alpha, or hydrogen
in alpha, we could put methyl in
alpha.
But there's a problem here.
Because we also have the
possibility that it could
react here.
So "Which nucleophile wins?"
is the question.
I think I probably should let
you go now, and we'll go on to
resolve the Perils of Pauline
the next time.